never know what someone is doing behind
closed doors I have opened the door into
what I did but you'll never know what
people are doing and I've seen that oh
so there's more no business I'm not
saying there's more
there's people pretending this perfect
guy is there more
um
but there's people pretending to have
this perfect life and have it together
yeah and then it's only if you I worked
as a a medical secretary and it's only
when you like having someone's medical
records has changed my view on whatever
anyone says to me people could be
looking at me and saying oh she's a
[ __ ] she's a terrible thrower she's for
the streets but there's people that are
prim and proper and put together and
have had multiple diseases they've had
certain things wrong because of their
choices but you're not gonna see that so
my thing is you will never truly know
what someone has done you would you want
yeah I mean I agree with you what's your
point my point is that if we're gonna do
this proper people do [ __ ] up things
all the time
like with this whole like can you what's
a healthy relationship a healthy
relationship is meeting each other at
the point of one's needs and being
willing to work through whatever it is
if you are happy to take the single mom
deal if you want a good deal on a used
car that's you if you say you want it
brown no no a bad a bad deal on a bad
deal I don't think so don't say don't
say a good deal on anything it's a bad
deal so if you want if you want a bad
deal if you want to pay full price for a
used car okay sorry yeah yeah if you
want to pay
um
if you want a 5 000 car for a 40K
let her know DMR
yeah it's up to you yeah listen I think
there's too much talk about like you
know oh yeah if you're a single mom you
might be able to find a guy because
there's some guys are maybe you should
shift your attention onto talking to
young girls I did not make not you
personally don't take I School them yeah
well I'm saying it should be more like
of a general thing that a lot of women
out there that are in that single mother
position should be talking to a lot of
younger girls this is the reality
quality like and if you get to a certain
age probably you guys are not going to
want to couple up with you marry you or
anything you're going to be on your own
because that is the reality
and that's the thing a lot of them will
be homeless or they'll be their kids
responsibility and so and so it's like
the church is is teaching them to wait
and they're going to leave women
homeless
and that's that's the reality do you
know what I think the root of everything
is this generation has a lot of trauma
and in their lives
um and we're raising
children who well and our generation
that have been traumatized in some way
of maybe their their family situation so
they are going on to have children that
are also like seeing that as a who are
traumatized because we glorify a single
motherhood yeah yeah
and there you go and and give them
bailouts in the church I'm just saying
if you look at the way the benefit
system's set up in this country and I
know you're a fan of Thomas Soul so
you've seen how it works with the
welfare state in the US but here if
you're in a couple living together you
get less benefits than if you were two
single people living separately so
there's a financial incentive for people
to separate yeah so if you pay more
people to be single mothers more will be
single mothers 100 100
I have a friend that's married and when
during lockdown her husband was not
working
she didn't get any help off the premise
that you're married but she needed the
help because in that circumstance she
was taking on the full burden on one
income of the household vodka's welfare
is built off the backs of man yes it is
yeah everything everything is for women
it is and yeah everything's for women
it's true I think there was less
government support to be a single mom it
would cut down a man once said single
mothers are state-sponsored terrorists
okay I want to bring in something
um why is it that we are not um
encouraging men to kind of protest these
laws that are not in their favor
there are a lot of laws because no one
cares until women no yeah because they
don't care no no no I mean like like for
example like let's talk about like if
girl
like let's let's talk about women's
issues like what like violence against
women people laugh at violence against
men and so anytime anytime men bring
their issues to the Forefront people
don't care until women bring it women
decide elections okay so I I work in um
social care so I'm in and out of
people's homes a lot and a deal a lot
with people's relationships
um usually when there's a an issue and
one of the things that I've seen over
and over again is when there's issues in
relationship and the woman Source says
oh she's thinking about leaving and the
social worker will respond straight away
and say yeah and I've seen on a number
of occasions when
um people who are interacting well when
I was working in support housing when a
woman's pregnant a very common question
for them to ask this woman would be are
you going to put a father on the birth
certificate you should think about not
doing that because then he'll have
parental responsibility he'll have all
sorts of complications and I've seen
this conversation happen again and again
and again and the amount of times I've
seen social workers
failed to contact fathers uh when
they're discussing matters relating to
the child but they'll always prioritize
contacting the woman
and generally giving preferential
treatment to women in terms of contact
it is getting better in some regards
like I do see glimmers of Hope in it but
I can repeatedly see this Dynamic where
women are given the power in relation to
the child okay my point is
in back in the days it was the reverse
women had to fight to get what they are
getting today that's my point not
necessarily
yeah they did have to voice out and Men
joined them for what to to get this
support that they are getting today what
type of support suppose in terms of
um child support support in terms of the
welfare system that's favoring them
support in terms of the family cost
system that favors the woman yeah so
bailouts yeah but it's not like we were
discriminated against we just wanted
bailouts for bad decisions no that's
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that the women had to speak up
how to rise up and a lot of men joined
that that that train that's what I'm
saying
okay
what I'm saying in this case is that
since the system is
mostly against men I believe that men
should also rise up to
and speak out against it
funny thing is that you are a lady and
you are joining us to speak out against
it so I think that we should speak out
against it but we are not most of the
time men are not are not saying anything
they will they go on podcasts like this
or go within their friends and and they
and they they talk to their friends and
that's where it ends why aren't we
taking this further into try to bring us
try to bring this up at work and see
what happens yeah
safe space to have these conversations
if a man goes into work and starts
demanding changes of this capacity they
will take the [ __ ] out of it straight
away so it's not that mental want to
speak out it's that they can't speak up
and women women just have all the power
we decide elections
um yes I know even even in the US they
took um I mean I would assume it's
usually similar in in different places
like from the US to the UK but they they
said if um only men voted it would be
Republican like 90 of the time
because women vote with their emotions
go ahead are you saying that men
shouldn't do anything about the
situation it's just I think well I think
I think all groups that exist because
there's there is the term men's rights
activists and there are groups that
campaign for men's rights but often
men's rights activists is used as a slur
or a pejorative to say you know
it's used as another word for misogynist
and it isn't a misogynist and if you
look at a lot of what what these men are
campaigning for you know people like um
Warren Farrell's a really public speaker
against the sort of imbalances that uh
disadvantage men and the issues around
fatherhood and he gets branded and
misogynist but he spent most of the 80s
in the feminist movement and he's got no
issue with women and most people in the
men's rights activist Community I mean
there are in inevitably exceptions who
take it to the extreme but most of them
are saying there are women's issues and
there are men's issues why can't we
address both of them why do we just have
to talk about Whimsy women's issues and
the response they usually get is that
makes you a sexist and a misogynist and
a bigot and I'm trying I'm trying to
find it too but women get way more
funding for women's issues than men yeah
agencies that are dedicated to right
it's a multi it's like a billion dollar
industry in in that it's a billion
dollar industry that is on the bat like
the whole point is to when that women
need to be victims otherwise they stop
getting funding in fact women's
empowerment a violence against women if
women aren't victims they stop getting
funding and it's like the men they can
protest but they can't get billions of
dollars to raise awareness and fight and
they're too busy working yeah and doing
dangerous doing the dangerous jobs as
well I'm of the opinion that if men
speak out more and support each other
you see you can see the support among
among the women
is dead men I feel that men need to
support each other speak for each other
we are not we are not really doing that
we are not really doing a good job of
that many times yeah
I just think it's because they can't
you can't yeah they can't because as
Eddie was saying earlier I just think
there's it's a risk versus rewards but
I'm of the opinion that men do not
realize the value that they hold in the
society I agree there is there is a
problem in which men are given a
perceived value that this is your value
and and they take it yes if they know
their true value
when a man speaks people should listen
agreed that that's that's my take on
that I I don't think that oh because the
the people in the in the in the in this
in the company are against demands for
saying that no if everybody understands
their value in the society
when a man is saying something you
shouldn't wait on a woman to say the
same thing before you listen to the
Bible but then can I also also say is
subjective
when you come out
oh yeah yeah in Africa it's not like
this
so it's I don't know the Arabian world
again
I've heard I get a lot of messages from
guys like all over the world and I I've
been getting more from like third world
countries saying feminism is impacting
us here it was currently better like
especially especially I don't know I
haven't looked at it in into it too much
but even like places like India yeah
where that have one of the best marriage
rates like I I've heard that I I don't I
don't want to speak on it too much
because I don't know enough as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible